we've evolved with tools and tools have
evolved with us our ancestors created
these hand axes 1.5 million years ago
shaping them to not only fit the task at
hand but also their hand however over
the years tools have become more and
more specialized these sculpting tools
have evolved through their use and each
one has a different form which matches
its function and they leverage the
dexterity of our hands in order to
manipulate things with much more
precision but as tools have become more
and more complex we need more complex
controls to control them and so
designers have become very adept at
creating interfaces that allow you to
manipulate parameters while you're
attending to other things such as taking
a photograph and changing the focus or
the aperture but the computer has
fundamentally changed the way that we
think about tools because computation is
dynamic so it can do a million different
things and run a million different
applications however computers have the
same static physical form for all these
different applications in the same
static interface elements as well and I
believe that this is fundamentally a
problem because it doesn't really allow
us to interact with our hands and
capture the rich dexterity that we have
in our bodies and my belief is that then
we must need new types of interfaces
that can capture this rich abilities
that we have and that can physically
adapt to us and allow us to interact in
new ways and so that's what I've been
doing at the MIT Media Lab and now at
Stanford so with my colleagues daniel
lighting Durant Hiroshi Ishii we created
inform where the interface can actually
come off the screen and you can
physically manipulate it or you can
visualize 3d information physically and
touch it and feel it to understand it in
new ways
or you can interact through gestures and
direct deformations to sculpt digital
play or interface elements can arise out
of the surface and change on demand and
the idea is that for each individual
application the physical form could be
matched to the application and I believe
this represents a new way that we can
interact with information by making it
physical so the question is how can we
use this
so traditionally urban planners and
architects build physical models of
cities and buildings to better
understand them so with Tony Tang at the
Media Lab we created an interface built
on in form to allow urban planners to
design and view entire cities and now
you can walk around it but it's dynamic
its physical and you can also interact
directly or you can look at different
views such as population or traffic
information but it's made physical we
also believe that these dynamic shape
displays can really change the ways that
we remotely collaborate with people so
when we're working together in person
I'm not only looking at your face but
I'm also gesturing and manipulating
objects and that's really hard to do
when you're using tools like Skype and
so using inform you can reach out from
the screen and manipulate things at a
distance so we use the pins of the
display to represent people's hands
allowing them to actually touch and
manipulate objects at a distance and you
can also manipulate and collaborate on
3d datasets as well so you can just
around them as well as manipulate them
and that allows people to collaborate on
these new types of 3d information in a
richer way that might be possible with
traditional tools and so you can also
bring in existing objects and those will
be captured on one side and transmitted
to the other or you can have an object
that's linked between two places so as I
move a ball on one side the ball moves
on the other as well and so we do this
by capturing the remote user using a
depth sensing camera
like a Microsoft Kinect now you might be
wondering how does this all work and
essentially what it is is 900 linear
actuators that are connected to these
mechanical linkages that allow motion
down here to be propagated in these pins
above so it's not that complex compared
to what's trying out at CERN but it did
take a long time for us to build it and
so we started with a single motor a
single linear actuator and then we had
to design a custom circuit board to
control them and then we had to make a
lot of them and so the problem with
having 900 of something is that you have
to do every step 900 times and so that
meant that we had a lot of work to do so
we sort of set up a mini sweatshop in
the Media Lab and brought undergrads in
and convinced them to do research and
you know had had late nights watching
movies eating pizza and screwing and
thousands of screws you know research
but anyway I think that we were really
excited by the things that inform
allowed us to do increasingly we're
using mobile devices and we interact on
the go but mobile devices just like
computers are used for so many different
applications so you use them to talk on
the phone to surf the web to play games
to take pictures or even a million
different things but again they have the
same static physical form for each of
these applications and so we wanted to
know how do we take some of the same
interactions that we develop for inform
and bring them to mobile devices so at
Stanford we created this haptic edge
display which is a mobile device with an
array of linear actuators that can
change shape so you can feel in your
hand where you are as you're reading a
book or you can feel in your pocket new
types of tactile sensations that are
richer than the vibration or buttons can
emerge from the side that allow you to
interact where you want them to be or
you can play games and have actual
buttons and so we were able to do this
by embedding 40 small tiny linear
actuators inside the device and that
allows you not only to touch them but
also back drive them as well but we've
also looked at other ways to create more
complex
shape change so we've used pneumatic
actuation to create a morphing device
where you can go from something that
looks a lot like a phone to a wristband
on-the-go and so together with Ken dr.
Jackie at the Media Lab we created this
new high-resolution version that uses a
array of servo motors to change from
interactive wristband to touch input
device to a phone and we're also
interested in looking at ways that users
can actually deform the interfaces to
shape them into the devices that they
want to use so you can make something
like a game controller and then the
system will understand what shape it's
in and change to that mode so where does
this point how do we move forward from
here I think really where we are today
is in this new age of the Internet of
Things where we have computers
everywhere they're in our pockets
they're in our walls they're in almost
every device that you'll buy in the next
five years but what if we stop thinking
about devices and think instead about
environments and so how do we have smart
furniture or smart rooms or smart
environments or cities that can adapt to
us physically and and allow us to do new
new ways of collaborating with people
and doing new types of tasks so for the
Milan Design Week we created transform
which is an interactive table scale
version of these shape displays which
can move physical objects on the surface
for example reminding you to take your
T's but it can also transform to fit
different ways of interacting so if you
want to work then it can change to sort
of set up your work system and so as you
bring a device over it creates all the
affordances that you need and brings
other objects to help you accomplish
those goals so in conclusion I really
think that we need to think about a new
fundamentally different way of
interacting with computers we need
computers that can physically adapt to
us and adapt to the ways that we want to
use them
and really harness the rich dexterity
that we have of our hands and our
ability to think spatially about
information by making it physical but
looking forward I think we need to go
beyond this beyond devices to really
think about new ways that we can bring
people together and bring our
information into the world and think
about smart environments that can adapt
to us physically so with that I will
leave you thank you very much